the geological history of the earth
Bears the traces of many global climate
changes
variations in temperature radiation
levels and the composition of the
planet's atmosphere have proved to be a
verdict for some species and an
evolutionary impetus for others
some major extinctions wiped out up to
90 percent of the species of our time
bringing life on the planet to the brink
of Extinction
over the last 500 million years there
have been five such Global catastrophes
and right now according to statistics a
sixth one is a progress and the fastest
known in terms of running its course
what is happening on our planet and why
is its biosphere degrading so rapidly
let's try to find out
[Music]
the earth's climate like that of any
other Celestial body is determined by a
combination of a huge number of factors
some of these are external such as
variations in cellular activity or the
rhythmic deformation of the planet's
orbit
others are caused by the Earth itself
to answer the question of what is
happening now and what to expect in the
future we need to travel back tens of
millions of years to find out how the
face of our planet was changing and what
factors were influencing climate change
right now you're looking at a graph on
the screen that shows the change in the
average temperature of our planet over
500 million years
by putting together data from
excavations around the world scientists
have been able to accurately determine
the earth's climate in each period
looking at the big picture it is easy to
see that long and hot intervals were
followed by shorter periods of cooling
during these periods called ice ages the
climate was drier temperatures were
lower and ice caps were building up at
the pearls of our planet just the way
they look now
each Global change in the average
temperature of our planet was a trial
for its inhabitants and not everyone
made it
foreign
approximately 66 million years ago
a huge 10 kilometer asteroid is rapidly
approaching our planet
just minutes later it pierces the
atmosphere and crashes to the surface
[Music]
a definite explosion of the power of
millions of thermonuclear bombs shakes
the Earth
[Music]
the violent Shockwave crashes and blasts
away rocks
forming a gigantic crater about 180
kilometers across
many of the rocky fragments are thrown
out of the atmosphere into space
they later fall back on the planet
thousands of kilometers from the
explosion
causing widespread forest fires
[Music]
the shock wave is believed to have
traveled around the entire planet
causing earthquakes in its furthest
reaches while a gigantic tsunami
destroyed the coasts of continents they
penetrated hundreds of kilometers Inland
ramming everything in their path
15 trillion tons of suit and dust were
sucked into the air and blown across the
Earth
for many years our planet received far
less sunlight than usual
causing a dramatic Cooling
according to research for at least 16
years after the disaster the average
temperature of the planet remained
around 3 degrees Celsius which is 11
degrees lower than it is now
as a result most terrestrial and aquatic
plants became extinct causing a massive
famine among animals
almost all creatures weighing over 25
kilos including flightless dinosaurs and
Aquatic lizards vanished from the face
of the Earth
some did not survive the catastrophe
itself others fell victim to its
consequences
thus began the cenozoic a new era in the
history of our planet
for the next 10 million years referred
to as the paleoc in Epoch the Earth was
recovering from this cataclysmic event
the volcanic ash clouds gradually
dissipated and temperatures Rose rapidly
to comfortable levels
step by step life repopulated the baron
expresses of the planet but this time it
was completely different species
flowering plants mammals and birds
the end of the paleocene was marked by a
rapid rise in temperature largely
attributed to tectonic activity during
this period
volcanic eruptions in the North Atlantic
Ocean released great amounts of methane
and carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
with concentrations as high as 2 000
parts per million five times higher than
today's levels
this warming is considered to be the
beginning of a new Epoch called the air
scene
it started about 56 million years ago
and persisted for about 22 million years
during this time the average temperature
of our planet was noticeably higher than
it is today at times as high as 28
degrees Celsius
paleontological evidence suggests that
during the year scene the climate of
most of the land was close to that in
the tropics and dense broad-leaved
forests reached as far as the polar
circles at the time palms and
heat-loving reptiles are known to have
inhabited the area of today's Europe the
main reason for this is thought to be
the favorable location of the continents
at that time North and South America
were separated by broad Strait
African Eurasia had not yet made contact
either
equatorial currents and Atmospheric
currents were therefore free to travel
across the Earth Distributing heat
relatively evenly over it in addition
the abundance of decomposing organic
matter maintained high levels of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere which also
helped the climate to remain warm
thanks to the mild conditions and
abundance of food mammals of this time
experienced growth from Tiny marsupials
hiding in Burrows and Treetops to
Majestic Giants weighing tens of tons it
was also during this period that the
ancestors of most of today's mammals the
ancient primates cetaceans and rodents
appeared
however the face of the Earth continued
to change slowly but steadily
the spread of the Aquatic Fern are Zola
in Northern Waters led to a gradual drop
in atmospheric carbon dioxide levels and
a gradual Cooling
and around 34 35 million years ago there
is an unexpected sharp break in the
temperature graph
during this period on the border between
the ear scene and oligacy in epochs a
number of very important events took
place first the Collision of the
continents caused Majestic mountain
ranges to rise to the heavens such as
the Himalayas the Alps the carpathians
and the Appalachian Mountains
significantly affecting air currents in
the atmosphere
secondly analysis of the fossils showed
that it was at this time that a new type
of photosynthesis called C4 began to
spread actively among plants
this turned out to be much more
efficient than the previous type of
reaction and this gradually led to an
increase in atmospheric oxygen
concentration by two to three percent up
to today's levels
the carbon dioxide content on the other
hand dropped markedly resulting in a
weakening of the Greenhouse Effect and a
global drop in temperature
thirdly this mess between South America
and Antarctica was broken up by the
movement of tectonic plates
as a result the forces of inertia caused
by the Earth's rotation formed a closed
ocean current that enclosed the
southernmost continent of our planet in
a curl drain their currents also formed
an impenetrable barrier preventing Warm
Winds from entering Antarctica
as a result temperatures on the
continent began to drop rapidly and by
the end of the Paleo Gene its green
forests had been permanently replaced by
fast growing glaciers
all of these events heralded the
beginning of a new Epoch The oligar
Scene It persisted for about 11 million
years during which the climate of our
planet was relatively steady dry and
cool
and at the same time noticeably warmer
than today
this tendency continued into the
beginning of the next Epoch the Maya
scene
however at about 14 million years ago on
the graph we see another abrupt cooling
it is called the middle myocene
disruption and is thought to have been
caused by a combination of two factors
first of all the Earth in its orbital
motion once again entered the code phase
of the so-called milankovic Cycles
melankovic Cycles are periodic
fluctuations in the amount of solar
energy reaching our planet depending on
changes in the position of the Earth's
axis and its orbit
when the eccentricity of the Earth's
orbit reaches higher values and the
winter solstice coincides with the
perihelion the planet's climate becomes
significantly cooler
this is what happened 14 million years
ago during the middle myocene disruption
as a consequence of this cooling forests
declined getting largely replaced by
savannas and steps this stimulated the
spread of flowering plants using C4
photosynthesis as more resilient and
competitive ones
as a result the level of carbon dioxide
in the planet's atmosphere drastically
dropped leading to even more cooling to
understand the natural processes of this
period it is worth remembering that the
Savannah and similar biomes are highly
biologically productive systems one
square kilometer of Savannah produced up
to 1500 tons of biomass a year almost
the equivalent of living creatures
inhabiting this area
highly nutritious grasses with short
lifespans nourished herbivores ensuring
rapid recycling of nutrients including
carbon
as a consequence The increased Savannah
area helped to lower concentrations of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and
lead to a further drop in temperature
as a result in the course of several
million years the average global
temperature dropped by about 6 degrees
from 17 degrees Celsius to 11 degrees
making most of the megaphone of the
previous period extinct
the most notable animals of this time
when humorous drunked animals as well as
the prehistoric ancestors of Horses The
hipparians the largest carnivores were
amphis ionidi and hyenodons which
weighed up to half a ton
[Music]
following the graph it is easy to see
that starting with the middle myocene
disruption the Earth cooled down
smoothly and inexorably the consequence
was a rapid growth of glaciers in the
second polar regions of the planet which
began about 8 million years ago the
Antarctic ice sheet began to grow
rapidly a non-melting polar cap formed
in the Arctic Ocean and the forests of
Greenland began to disappear rapidly
giving way to glaciers however with a
main ordeal was yet to come
around 2.6 million years ago the
temperature drop noticeably accelerated
at about this time the movement of the
continents and a drop in the global sea
level led to the formation of the
Isthmus of Panama which firmly sealed
off the strait between North and South
America
as a result the warm equatorial Waters
of the Pacific could no longer mix with
the Atlantic currents and the Atlantic
temperatures gradually began to fall
in addition the Rocky Mountains having
grown considerably by this time
presented an obstruction to warmer air
currents further disrupting the
circulation of heat around the planet
as a consequence the seasonal
temperature variations over much of the
land became even more pronounced and the
rate of Glacier growth increased
substantially
around the same time the so-called gorse
matiama reversal occurred during which
the Earth's magnetic pearls reversed
once again
fifteen thousand years the protective
field of our planet was about four times
weaker than it is today leading to the
extinction of several families of marine
animals and algae
this event allowed us to speak at the
beginning of a new geological period the
pleistocene
glacias became its characteristic
feature they would Advance sometimes
occupying up to 30 percent of the land's
surface then Retreat beyond the polar
Circle but they never disappeared
completely
the first half of the pleistocene was
remarkably consistent with warming and
cooling periods occurring every 41 000
years this periodicity coincides very
closely with the milankovic cycles
so it is thought that it is these
natural fluctuations in the Earth's
orbit that caused it
the movement of glaciers and climatic
shifts inevitably affected the Flora and
Fauna
reshaping the planet's inhabitants
global cooling forced many herbivores to
put on a furry coat and grow larger to
withstand the cold
thus mammoths and mastodons Woolly
rhinoceroses and other herbivorous
Giants appeared carnivores were forced
to follow suit
North America for example was home to
the great polar bear a fearsome Beast
estimated to weigh up to 1 200 kilograms
three to four times more that is today's
relatives
a little further south lived the
so-called dire wolves which were about
twice the size of today's wolves it has
been suggested that these Predators
hunted in packs of three or four and
thanks to their strength and coordinated
action were capable of driving and
killing bison
meanwhile around 1 million years ago the
periodicity of Glacier onset was
disrupted the cooling Cycles became
irregular and their duration increased
substantially to an average of one
hundred thousand years as a consequence
the temperature contrast was more
dramatic and the thickness of glaciers
varied more as well this transformation
is called the middle pleistocene
transition and its causes are not yet
fully explored
the most feasible version is that when
moving earlier glaciers wiped away the
layers of regolith that covered the
bedrock in the northern latitudes the
new glaciers froze over less slippery
rocks such as granites and basalts thus
disrupting the established cyclicity
another reason could have been the
blocking of the Bering Strait caused by
a drop in the sea level and Rising
glaciers this event occurred about nine
hundred thousand years ago and caused
curled water from the Pacific Ocean to
stop flowing into the Arctic Ocean
this resulted in a further drop in
temperature and increased Cooling
also throughout the pleistocene the
ancestors of modern humans gradually
spread across the planet
researchers have documented traces of
several Global migrations and many
smaller ones
as nomadic gatherers and Hunters these
ancient tribes explored new lands
competing into breeding and dividing
giving rise to dozens of different forms
some left behind only bones and
abandoned sights others were much more
fortunate
they were to become the ancestors of all
modern humans
the late pleistocene also known as upper
blistocene began 129
000 years ago and continued for 117
000 years
it was a time of Maximum Cooling and the
largest glaciers in a fierce struggle
for survival the crowmanian ancestors of
modern humans wiped out or assimilated
all other human communities
in an effort to escape the dangers
ancient tribes spread Beyond Eurasia and
Africa thanks to a land passage in what
is now the Bering Strait they entered
North America in several stages thus
becoming the ancestors of numerous
Indian tribes around the same time a few
thousand kilometers further south a drop
in sea level opened away to Australia
and so around 50 000 years ago humans
arrived in this isolated world too
lacking systematic knowledge of the
environment a prehistoric man was unable
to comprehend the long-term consequences
of his actions and treated nature in a
highly exploitative manner
Australia appeared as a green Paradise
full of easy prey unused to humans the
slow and not very smart giant marsupials
such as diprotodons and polycastes
proved unable to stand up to the new
predator
which was smart and came in big numbers
just 10 000 years later most of
Australia's animals larger than 45
kilograms were exterminated to hunt them
Aboriginal Australians actively torched
vegetation causing Fierce forest fires
most of the game hunted in this way was
lost and the scorched out area was left
with a semi-desert of sparse grass and
scrub at best
Australia's climate is arid and the soil
is not very fertile so once a forest is
destroyed it cannot regenerate on its
own
eventually when sea levels rose again
Australians were trapped on a parched
continent unable to feed their expanding
population
after violent fighting and prolonged
famine the population was reduced to
Optimum levels as it were but the path
to civilization was closed to the local
tribes
the blister scene is thought to have
ended about 11 700 years ago with the
end of the last cooling period glaciers
retreated
sea levels Rose by 35 meters and some
regions of the earth developed
distinctive previously unseen biomes
the best known of these were the Nile
Valley and Mesopotamia but in fact there
were many more
the abundance of water and fertile soil
was favorable for grains
the seeds of which are highly nutritious
the tribes living nearby no longer had
to roam in search of food the gifts of
nature were plentiful
thus non-migratory or sedentary
Gathering Lifestyles established
themselves to later evolve into farming
the peculiarity of Agriculture is that
its products need to be processed and
stored this nade stimulated the
development of construction and pottery
followed by metal working this is how
the history of ancient civilizations
began
technology gradually became more
sophisticated and human impact on the
environment increased
deforestation and plowing irrigation and
drainage toxic handicrafts and urban
growth gradually degraded the
environment in the vicinity of human
settlements for a long time however
these changes were localized and took
centuries to become irreversible
this began to change rapidly in the 18th
century with the start of the Industrial
Revolution the ever-increasing number of
factories led to a dramatic rise in
carbon dioxide emissions sulfur oxides
and other substances were released into
the atmosphere as well reacting with
water vapor and forming strong acids
these aggressive compounds settled and
accumulated in soils and bodies of water
gradually making the lattice
uninhabitable
second half of the 20th century saw a
particularly rapid rise in emissions
tens of thousands of power plants and
factories sprang up around the world and
Rising living standards and
technological advances led to motorized
transport becoming widespread
the passenger car may not seem to
produce much waste
the truth is that it emits an average of
15 kilograms of carbon dioxide per day
it adds up to five and a half tons a
year
and if we consider that there are about
a billion cars and 400 million trucks on
the planet at the moment it is obvious
that the total amounts to billions of
tons also bear in mind thermal power
plants and factories which contribute
even more to the pollution of the planet
in 2022 humans would have emitted about
38 billion tons of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere
one might sometimes hear that this
amount is minuscule compared to volcanic
emissions but this is a dangerous
misconception
if you look at the scientific data you
will find that volcanoes ejects a mere
260 million tons of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere each year about
150 times less than the human impact
if we look at the graph of atmospheric
CO2 levels we'll see that they have
already reached 400 parts per million
which is about 35 percent higher than in
the entire history of mankind
the last time carbon dioxide levels in
the Earth's atmosphere were close to
this was about 5 million years ago
before the global Ice Age
[Music]
and worst of all the figure has been
reached in less than a hundred years
with the increase still in progress
what threat does this process pose
first and foremost Rising global
temperatures will cause glaciers to melt
and this is already happening
Greenland's largest glacier jakobshaven
for example has increased its rate of
melting fulfilled since the turn of the
century every year its Edge Retreats
three to seven kilometers inland
the process has slowed somewhat in
recent years but scientists believe it
is a temporary spite also warming is
already causing the permafrost to melt
this makes many settlements and Northern
latitudes uninhabitable and marine
fisheries are severely affected by the
unstable ice cover
it should be remembered that permafrost
is a gigantic planetary refrigerator in
which billions of tons of organic matter
is Frozen Once melted it will begin to
decompose transforming into carbon
dioxide and methane thus accelerating
the warming further calculations show
that a fall of the Earth's size caps
were to melt the sea level would rise by
66 meters
cities such as New York Saint Petersburg
Shanghai London and many others will be
partially or completely flooded
entire countries and regions such as the
Netherlands Polynesia or the Amal
Peninsula will disappear
millions of square kilometers of coastal
land will be submerged and fertile land
and human settlements there will be
destroyed forever
rapid warming will lead to the
degradation of many areas forest fires
will increase and deserts will grow even
larger a combination of these factors
will inevitably lead the world into a
new Global Extinction and it would have
begun by now
over the last 500 years around a
thousand species of large animals have
disappeared from the face of the Earth
more than 35
000 species of vertebrates insects and
land plants and are threatened with
Extinction including forty percent of
all amphibians and 25 percent of mammal
species
these include ones important to humans
plants such as bananas and species such
as honeybees their demise could change
our world forever
and not for the better at all
the modern humans imagine themselves to
be wise and civilized yet at times
behave even more recklessly than
prehistoric humans unreasonable ambition
and the pursuit of profit of power have
repeatedly led to environmental
disasters showing that the modern man is
not far removed from the prehistoric
Australian Aborigines who destroyed the
flourishing land they had inherited with
their own hands
if we do not learn to take care of our
planet
will end ignominiously within it and we
will only dream
about distant Stars
dear friends the climate change issue
inevitably affects each and every one of
us that is why feel free to express your
opinion in the comments below
it has taken two long months of energy
consuming efforts to make this video and
we hope you enjoyed it
if you feel strongly about the issues
raised share it with your friends and
like it if you feel it was worth
watching thanks to your support more
people will find out about it
and perhaps it will make the world a
tiny bit better
let's keep in touch
foreign